the jurgen experience what made you
want to write about testosterone what
was the motivation behind this
so i'll give you the short story first
and then later i can give you the longer
story the longest the longer story
involves chimpanzees
oh kind of one of my favorite subjects
um but the short story is
that t i teach at harvard about hormones
i teach a course behavioral well it's on
behavioral endocrinology it's called
hormones and behavior
and i've taught that for a long time now
and i got my phd at harvard studying
testosterone and
behavior studying sex differences in the
way we think and process
information and i love
i just love the topic i love how much
understanding testosterone helps me
understand the world understand men
i'm not a man i don't really understand
men
uh or how they work but understanding
this hormone really
has helped me a lot and then in
teaching about endocrinology and
specifically testosterone
i get so much feedback from students
about how it changes
their lives changes how they understand
themselves
personally how they understand their
relationships how they understand the
world
and it's empowering for them and it's
been empowering for me
and so
i've just always had this natural
intellectual enthusiasm
for this topic and but
i'd say in the last five years i felt
like the science
was coming under attack and there's been
kind of a program to dismantle
the science of testosterone and how it
shapes behavior
particularly the evolutionary basis of
behavior
um has kind of come under attack the
idea that there that sex differences are
grounded in biology and i know that
testosterone is a really important part
of that
and uh there's a movement to kind of
discredit
that science or downplay the importance
of biology and specifically testosterone
in our lives and especially in sex
differences and i'm fascinated
by sex differences and i'm fascinated by
how evolution shapes sex differences
across
different species and how it works and
so that's
ultimately why i wrote the book because
i kind of want to get all the science
out there
and kind of push back against what i see
as an attack on really
good science there's nothing wrong with
understanding who we are from a
biological
point of view uh and i think we should
all be open to that and learn as much as
we can about who we are
and how we work yeah i i agree with you
and but i also think it's fascinating
when i watch
the attack on the science of biology the
science of
how if you like i think that if we were
an objective observer like something
other than human
and we're watching human beings we would
be really interested
in the the sex differences between the
male and the females
and what's why are there there's like
this real clear pattern of behavior on
both sides
obviously there's a spectrum in that
pattern but
depending upon the levels of hormones
and the genetic variants there's a lot
of
like consistency and what is causing
this and what is
you know what is it about male behavior
that leads to this and female behavior
that
leads to that but then you get into this
weird thing
where ideology has somehow or another
overtaken science with a lot of human
beings today
so they're willing to abandon science
if it's inconvenient for their ideology
it's very strange
because you see really intelligent
people doing yes yes which is where it's
really spooky because they're scared
of being chastised and attacked on
twitter they're scared of being canceled
so they're scared of going against
the mainstream which is ideologically
based instead of scientifically based
that's right and i think the fear is
that the science is getting in the way
of the ideology
so we i agree with
most of the goals of the people who are
ideologically motivated we want to
reduce human suffering
we want to have make sure that we have
equal human rights for people who have
all kinds of differences
and so i agree with all that but i don't
think that
if science tells us that some of these
differences are grounded in biology
that means that a these traits that may
be
uh like extreme male aggression that
doesn't mean that that's immutable
i mean we have tons of evidence that
it's not immutable humans have control
over their behavior it depends heavily
on the culture so denying the importance
of say testosterone in male aggression
isn't going to change the way the sort
of differences in our natures
or the impetus for males to feel
um more than females that they
want to be physically aggressive or to
respond aggressively in certain
situations and i like that you said that
there's you
implied that there's lots of overlap in
behavior between males and females and
the degree to which that is grounded in
biology
so the point isn't and i just want to
make it really clear at the beginning
it's not that females are like this and
males are like that in
human in humans or in other species and
especially you know culture plays such a
huge role
in how we develop and how we express
ourselves but even
apart from culture there are differences
on average so there are some females who
are highly physically aggressive and
there are many males who are really
emotional and sensitive
and totally peaceful can i say what that
you just said you'd tear up sometimes i
cry all the time
okay i cried mostly for happy things
okay so
yeah no and i just cry when i'm moved or
passionate i cry a lot and i
actually talk about that in the book
because there's a relationship with
testosterone there that we can talk
about
later which is really interesting but
the point is that
you know my book tea is not
about not trying to explain why
males are one way and females are
another way but why we're different on
average why we have somewhat different
natures
and testosterone is to me the most
powerful way
to understand those differences in our
natures you know from an evolutionary
point of view and looking at how
we as animals as mammals
try to maximize our reproductive success
right and that's so that's what
testosterone does is it helps
males maximize basically the number of
offspring they have through increasing
mating opportunities
it doesn't mean that males are only
interested in
having tons of sex and tons of sex
partners but they're definitely
more interested in that than females in
humans and in many
other species where increasing the
number of mates you know yields
reproductive benefits for males but not
females
and that's what sex hormones do and
estrogen you know and progesterone do
similar
things in women but it doesn't motivate
us to
fight aggressively for mates right
clearly if we were looking at this again
as an objective observer we would see
all this that would be without
there wouldn't be any debate it'd be
like this is fascinating well this is
why
they've only been around for a couple
hundred thousand years and for a long
time they were eaten by jaguars
and so they had to make as many babies
as possible in order to ensure survival
of the species
all this makes sense catch new episodes
of the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes you just need to search
for the jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience